el secretario general de la otan James
stolterberg ha presionado hoy desde
Estambul a Turquía para que levante el
Beto y acepte de una vez la entrada de
Finlandia y Suecia la otan algo que
lleva demorandose desde Primavera cuando
los dos países fueron aceptados en su
proceso de adhesión que aún no ha sido
ratificado todos los parlamentos de
todos los países miembros de la otan
tienen que ratificar la adhesión de un
nuevo país a la otan para que este sea
efectivo no lo han hecho dos son la o el
de Hungría de Víctor Urban y la Turquía
de perdón que ha dicho que ya es el
momento de que estos dos países sean
aceptados delante del ministro de
exteriores Turco mebluch abusó lo que ha
asegurado que no que Suecia en Finlandia
tienen que realizar a un pasos que les
quedan para que Turquía levante su reto
se refiere a la deportación de
ciudadanos kurdos residentes en Suecia a
los que Turquía acusa de ser miembros de
la guerrilla curvo turca del pkk que es
considerada terrorista por Turquía como
también lo es por la Unión Europea y los
Estados Unidos se espera que en la
semana que viene el martes la semana que
viene el Primer Ministro sueco viaje a
Turquía para reunirse con erdogan para
intentar presionarle Además para que
Turquía levante este veto algo que no se
prevé según los expertos que vaya a
ocurrir muchos consideran que Turquía
mantenderá su vector Hasta pasado este
año y bien entrado en el siguiente
podría ser que Turquía lo mantuviese
hasta las elecciones presidenciales en
Turquía programadas para junio de 2023